les états unis plus que jamais isolé
dans leur croisade contre l'iran
approuvé par deux pays seulement rejeté
par la chine et la russie
les 11 autres membres du conseil se sont
abstenus sur le vote de la résolution
américaine
parmi eux la france le royaume-uni ou
encore l'allemagne
alliée traditionnelle des états unis un
vote inexcusable dénonce washington les
états vis n'abandonnerons jamais nos
amis dans la région qui attendaient
davantage du conseil de sécurité
nous continuerons à travailler pour
faire en sorte que le régime
théocratique terroristes ne soit pas
libre d'acheter de vendre des armes qui
menace le coeur de l'europe du
moyen-orient et au-delà
le texte américain appelle à une
extension illimité de l'embargo dont
l'expiration en octobre prochain a été
fixé par l'accord international sur le
nucléaire iranien signé en 2015 téhéran
n'a pas manqué de relever l'échec
américain depuis 75 ans d'histoire des
nations unies
l'amérique n'a jamais été si isolé un
vote sanction pour washington donald
trump s'est retiré de l'accord sur le
nucléaire iranien en mai 2018 avant
d'imposer une série de sanctions
unilatérales à l'iran une méthode remise
en cause par les membres du conseil de
sécurité notamment la délégation
française
la fin de l'embargo pourrait avoir de
graves conséquences pour la sécurité et
la stabilité régionale cependant la
france s'est abstenue sur le projet de
résolution proposé car il ne constitue
pas une réponse adaptée
ce rejet de l'onu entache la crédibilité
américaine sur la scène internationale
dans un communiqué publié après le vote
les etats-unis affirment qu'ils ne
reculeront devant rien pour prolonger
l'embargo sur les ventes d'armes à
l'iran